Y como pueden vivir hasta los 100 años,
los ostras gigantes son indicadores vitales de salud de arrecifes de coral.
Por eso, cuando comienzan a desaparecer los arrecifes,
su ausencia se puede interpretar como una alarma
para que los científicos presten atención,
son como el canario en una mina de carbón.
Pero las ostras gigantes están en peligro.
La mayor ostra del mundo está en vías de extinción,
con una merma de más del 50 % de la población.
Los beneficios ecológicos de que existan ostras gigantes en los arrecifes de coral
solo persistirán si las poblaciones son sanas,
haciendo su conservación primordial.
Por eso, estoy aquí hoy para hablar por las ostras gigantes,
porque me preocupo de verdad por estos animales extraordinarios,
y porque ellos merecen nuestra atención.
Es hora de que de las ostras gigantes salgan de sus conchas
y muestren al mundo que, ellas también pueden ser heroínas de los océanos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)